design is the wallpaper of the model it
infuses our perception of existence
there's a sweet spot where art and
science meet spot between dimensions
where reality and Surrey allottee
interconnects an equation of curiosity
imagination surrealism and whimsy this
is the irrepressible hotel EMC to
[Music]
David listen wrote that human
consciousness is a collaboration a
meeting point between subject and object
person and space our spaces are
constructs and housings for our minds
frameworks for our consciousness what we
design and turn designs us back Steven
Johnson echoed this when he suggested
our thoughts shape our spaces and then
our spaces return the favor
we recognize that instinctively
implicitly there's harmony ters elegant
this extends to every detail at Hotel
EMC to the lighting the service the food
the art the colors the shapes the design
delighting us and eliciting our inner
whimsy
our sense of wonder Terence Mckenna said
you become what you behold we can
therefore design certain qualities
directly into our spaces we can script
architecture with the qualities that we
wish to revere and embody a science as
much as an art good architecture
embodies both artistic imagination and
mathematical genius or art meets science
good design marries science and art good
design can change perception high mood
shift psychology good design is a poetic
expression of mathematical elegance and
its effects are akin to an altered state
of consciousness
study the science of art da Vinci study
the art of science develop your senses
learn to see realize that everything
connects to everything else exactly like
nothing else
you